bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you
what a beautiful greeting this is a
greeting that Jesus greeted his
followers with Moses Abraham all the
messengers of God and the last and final
messenger the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him all they greeted their
followers with this greeting of peace
and we're greeting you here today with
that same greeting of peace now where
I'm very excited we're bringing out to
continue the story of one man's Road to
Islam who graduated with honors from the
Harvard University he was an ordained
minister a deacon who started preaching
the Bible at a very young age and he was
filling the churches people excited to
hear him speak going to seminary school
he's a Muslim now what happened did he
take a wrong turn or he took the right
turn tell us now well actually he's
going to tell us how he accepted Islam
when we come back here in a Deen show
you don't want to go nowhere
I love love love
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
is just to break the ice
assalamo alaikum alaikum Salaam for
those people now I wish you peace you
wished it back upon me and I told him
that's the greeting of all the prophets
yes and we also mentioned something
about the beard last week you want to
just fill in the blank
well Prophet Mohammed peace be upon him
instructed us to have beards yeah and
also in place has instructed us to just
let them grow
yeah so I've let my beard grow and we
addressed this lastly if you didn't see
last week's show that was part one - why
dr. Gerald Dirk's accepted Islam and I
had mentioned that some people came
can't get past one time I guess was
wearing a what do you call it a poofy
not a cool for you something else on the
top of the head and and I had to have
him address it and once he addressed
that people you know they just start to
understand a little better and then they
can appreciate it and what we said in
the first show is that Jesus most likely
he had a beard in any picture you see
supposedly they try to paint Jesus
you'll never see him without a beard how
all the prophets is a pious way of
trying to emulate not the movie stars
but the best of humanity the prophets of
the creator of the heavens and air this
all right so now we talked about and you
can see this in part one how you went
from at a young age teaching preaching
the Bible finishing and getting a
Divinity degree and going to seminary
school
and then from there sum it up along with
what I just said and then we'll go on to
the rest of the story how you actually
came to Islam well as we mentioned last
week in 1974 I graduated from Harvard
Divinity School with a Master of
Divinity I was an ordained minister in
the United Methodist Church but at that
point
I spent three months and that summer
filling pulpit sand to rural parishes in
Kansas and then in September of 1974 I
left the parish ministry for good I was
still an ordained minister I still
believe very definitely in God but
coming out of my seminary education as
we talked about last week I had no
belief in the divinity of Jesus or in
the concept of the Trinity in cetera so
I started a path that I called my path
of being an atypical Christian believed
very much in God pray read the Bible
studied new archaeological finds as they
came out on the Bible and other
Christian texts but again no belief in
the divinity of Jesus peace be upon him
no belief in a Trinity and I basically
continued in this line as an atypical
Christian from 1974 until 1993 but the
turning point actually started a couple
years before I became a Muslim it was
1991 and my wife and I for several years
had been doing research on the history
of the Arabian horse and we had some
Arabic documents what's the Arabian
horse the Arabian horse well yeah well
it's a horse for the perforin people who
are the the Arabian horse is a horse
that was bred for centuries by the
better ones of the Middle East okay they
typically have one less vertebrae in
their back and one less vertebrae in
their tail than other horses and they
are the preeminent endurance horse yes
so we've been studying the history of
the Arabian horse for a number of years
I've been writing about it and we had
some Arabic documents yeah Hodges that
it accompanied a shipment of horses in
1906 to the United States these were the
Arabic testimonials of purity and about
the origin of these horses that came
over in that year we wanted to get them
translated mm-hmm
and they hadn't been translated up to
this point in time yes and this brought
us into contact with the portion of the
Arab community
in Denver Colorado that happened to be
Muslim and our first such contact
occurred in the summer of 1991 and it
was with brother Jamal and he came out
to our farm looked at our horses glanced
at the Arabic documents and said sure
he'd be happy to translate them for us
mm-hmm
and we began that process a little bit
here a little bit there but along the
way a very close friendship developed
yes and before long we were spending
we're getting together on a weekly to
bi-weekly basis just socially you
weren't a little nervous
skeptical thinking like you know had
some preconceived ideas or notions that
you know which you might have seen on TV
that you know I gotta be careful this
guy might be a some kind of terrorist or
some kind of well again we're talking
1991 so it's a little before a little
before other than yeah but no I didn't
have any such feelings whatsoever along
the way and it's important I think to
point this out jebel never proselytized
mm-hmm he never said this is the way to
believe yes
he never said you ought to become a
Muslim mm-hmm however that first time he
came out to the farm before he left he
asked if he might use our restroom to
make ablution mm-hmm
before praying and he came out of the
restroom and I said you know may bar a
piece of newspaper to put on the floor
so that I can pray so this is the ritual
washing yes and then and we gave him the
the newspaper and he laid it out on the
floor and he did his prescribed prayer
yeah again he never said anything to us
about hey are you Muslims err
why aren't you Muslims yeah you should
be doing this his Dawa or his preaching
was in his behavior his actions okay his
example he prayed yeah a very powerful
form of preaching actually yeah describe
this prayer for us please it was the
standard Islamic prayer it had the
different postures you begin standing
and then there are some things that you
say this was during the day so he was
saying them to himself yeah
and then you you bow and then after
bowing you stand again and then you
prostrate and then you kneel and then
you prostrate and you go through this
cycle called Arica
did you think he was praying maybe to a
moon god or did you think of course huh
what did you think he was praying to God
to God yeah his understanding of God
yeah so anyway social contact continued
we were getting together once every week
every two weeks and as he continued to
translate stuff for us occasionally he
would begin to share with us knowledge
about the history of the Arabian horse
of the Middle East
yes and along the way of doing that he
began to quote different verses from the
Koran or different sayings of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him different
aspects of Islam not to proselytize but
to give us a way of understanding the
Islamic context of the history of the
Arabian horse yes so again it was all
presented not as proselytizing but as
you're interested in the history of the
Arabian horse I will seek to meet your
needs but in doing that I'm going to
have to explain this context to you so
you really understand it yes so this
continued on and over the next 16 months
our contact expanded not just with Jamal
but also with yl and his family with
honor and his family Ahmed and his
family and so just other Muslims and
other Muslims were getting together
socially again no active or direct
proselytizing going on but in the
process of observing
these Muslim brothers I became
increasingly impressed with their
behavior I mean they were living a very
moral and ethical life bending over
backwards to do it as a matter of fact
yeah I remember Jamel who ran at that
time sort of a mom-and-pop grocery store
in Denver
and I was at the store once when the
state waits inspector came by to examine
the scales yes and he examined them and
came told you now you know they're
within tolerance and Jamal said we'll
look this is what I want you to do I
want you to turn them against me to the
limits of what's tolerance in the state
yeah because I want to make sure I'm not
sure it changing my customers Wow so
this is the sort of behavior I was
observing there wasn't just ethics in
terms of their business life
it was the ethics in terms of their
family life the way they interacted with
their wives with their children etc very
powerful behavioural example and I
observed this for about 16 months and
finally oh it must have been in December
of 1992 I got around to asking myself to
sort of the fundamental question which
is what separates these Muslim friends
of mine from me in terms of belief
where's the difference mm-hmm now I I
had studied Islam sort of superficially
are briefly back at Harvard and the
comparative religions courses and but
this question was eating at me I mean
here are these people living these very
moral and upright lives my wife and I
have been trying to do that as well but
we felt that we were sort of doing that
within the context of a moral vacuum
yeah what separates me from them in
terms of actual religious beliefs but I
suppose I could have asked them yeah I
didn't want to okay I didn't want to
impinge on our friendship yeah and so I
went downstairs began dusting off all
the books on Islam I had acquired back
in those comparative religions courses
yes and they were all written by
non-muslim Western scholars and there's
probably half a dozen or more of them
and I took them down I reread them I
took down two different translations of
the meaning of the Quran I had acquired
back in those courses read them
and the more I read the more I said oh
wait a minute this is what I believe
starting to connect yeah very much
starting to connect and the other thing
that eventually happened in that process
was as I continued to read in the
English translations of the meaning of
the Quran especially where it was
talking about biblical history yes and
biblical concepts I saw within the Quran
statements about these things that I
knew could not have been known by any
illiterate seventh century Arab and of
course Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him was illiterate he didn't know how to
read write the history and confirms this
yes yes and he was known as the truth oh
yes yes and so now I'm left with a
question yeah where did this come from
so you're looking at this and you're
like that he can't he could come from
this man or any man no he couldn't have
known
uh-huh and so that left me with him with
the conclusion you know this had to be
inspired yeah however you want to define
inspired yeah in some sense this
knowledge was inspired by God
Wow and quite honestly brother I was
uncomfortable with that conclusion why I
didn't like that conclusion uh-huh
because that raised questions about my
own sense of religious identity yeah you
know I still continued to call myself a
Christian even though I was in a typical
Christian mm-hmm and I didn't like that
challenge to my sense of identity so
this is where things started about in
December of 1992 and in late December of
1992 my wife and I were talking about
this all the way through we were filling
out our passport application forms for a
proposed trip to the Middle East to do
some research on the history of the
Arabian horse and one of the questions
on the passport form was religious
affiliation mm-hmm well I didn't even
think about it
I just wrote in Christian and one huh
yeah and a few seconds later my wife
turned to me and said how did you fill
out the question
religious affiliation and I said well
commission of course and I left just as
you're laughing right now and then went
on to say you know I'm a Christian not a
Muslim now is it tames at the same time
is she doing her own research with you
along with yeah we're talking about it
all the welders
okay now the thing is in terms of this
story uh-huh you know I was trained have
a doctorate clinical psychology yeah you
know I was practicing psychotherapist I
knew that laughter is often a release of
psychological tension on huh and I had
laughed at this question yeah oh what
was the psychological tension that
needed to be released when my wife asked
me this innocuous question furthermore
why did I need to immediately follow it
up by saying I'm a Christian not a
Muslim you know a person does not defend
against an accusation that has not been
made now my wife hadn't said did you
write down Muslim in fact her response
when I said I'm a Christian not a Muslim
her immediately response was but no I
was inquiring whether you wrote down
Christian or Protestant or Methodist so
the accusation had come from my own
unconscious mind uh-huh you know there
was a part of my own unconscious mind
that was saying you're a Muslim yeah and
my conscious mind was like oh no I'm not
it's a batterer within there yeah it's a
battle with him and this battle
continued you know by January of 1993 I
was not reading my third different
English translation of the meaning in
the Quran you know cuz again I wasn't
going to trust these first two you know
I didn't like that conclusion I had come
to yeah that Muhammad peace be upon him
had been inspired by God because this
raised issues in terms of my own
identity yes well I continued studying
now and in January of 1993 I began
experimenting was saying the five daily
prayers of Islam alone in private and of
course in English because I didn't know
the Arabic to do yeah that way and I
found this very spiritually rewarding
very spiritually gratifying but again
I'm an atypical Christian
I may be an atypical Christian who
doesn't believe in the divinity of Jesus
who doesn't believe in the Trinity who's
reading the Quran every day in English
translation and as saying the five
prayers of Islam every day in English
but I'm still an atypical Christian yeah
well late in January in 1993 mm-hmm
it was my lunch hour at my private
practice I went to an Arab restaurant I
had started to frequent and I took with
me my third translation of the Quran
that I get some reading done over lunch
yeah and so I walked in I sat down and I
started reading and all of a sudden mood
the owner of the restaurant he was from
Damascus and Muslim came up to my table
to take my order he glanced down at what
I was reading but he didn't say anything
took my order and left and so I
continued reading well when my order was
ready instead of Mahmoud bringing it
back to me he sent his wife to bring it
to me who was an American he had a
convert to Islam oh she had accepted
oh yes yes and then or the hitch and the
scarf then I come to associate with
Muslim females and so sister you mom
came and she brought me my order and she
glanced down said oh I see you're
reading the Quran are you a Muslim and
the word was out of my mouth before it
could be modified by any social
etiquette whatsoever
I said no about that way brother and she
said oh that's okay and she turned
around and left and I said to myself my
goodness what is going on with it you
know I answered an innocuous question
rudely and aggressively this isn't like
me and I started stewing over at that as
I ate my lunch you know I'm gonna have
to make some amends to sister your mom
on when she comes back to bring me the
check for her meal and so I thought
about it and I thought about it and I
thought about it when the meal was over
she brought me to check and I said
something to the extent of the you know
I I think I answered your question a
little abruptly yeah when you asked me
whether I was a Muslim if you were
asking me whether I believe there is
only one God yeah my answer is yes
and if you were asking me whether I
believe that Muhammad peace be upon him
though I didn't say that at that point
was one of the prophets of God my answer
is yes so this is from researching now
looking into his life and reading the
cross that you're coming to this
conclusion yes but you just didn't want
to the identity now that is an issue
yeah and I knew at that point that in my
own English words I just said the
Shahada yeah or the Islamic testimonial
of faith uh-huh and sister Eman very
nicely smiled and said that's okay it
takes some people a little longer than
others left me yeah just do on it a
little more now again I knew I had just
said the Shahada but I was still in a
typical Christian mind you uh-huh you
know now I'm an atypical Christian who's
reading the Quran in English translation
saying the five daily prayers of Islam
in English and Yvonne is willing to say
that Shahada in my own carefully parsed
English words but I'm still in a typical
Christian I'm not a Muslim yeah if
somebody else some Muslim wants to take
what I've said and say you're a Muslim
that's their label of religious identity
just was not mine define what a Muslim
is really quickly just an in continue on
please well a Muslim is one by
definition by definition linguistically
one who submits and that's one who
submits to God but typically one says a
person becomes a Muslim when they say
the Shahada or the testimonial of faith
and that just made easy summed up with
one word in Arabic right mm-hmm that's
yeah simple okay so I'm still in a
typical Christian yeah and I think I'm
starting to sort my way out of this
challenge to my sense of religious
identity if someone asked me whether I'm
a Muslim
I'll go through a long five-minute song
and dance and which I'll say I don't
believe in the divinity of Jesus Christ
I don't believe in the Trinity I do
believe there is one and only one God I
do believe that Muhammad peace be upon
him was one of the prophets of God and
yes I'm saying the five prayers every
day and English that they're appointed
times in yes I'm reading English
translation of the meaning of the Quran
everyday but I'm an atypical Christian
mm-hmm and so that's sort of where
things were for a while how do you get
past this now well around the start of
March of that year Ramadan started yeah
and this of course is the month in which
Muslims fast from dawn to sunset well I
have all these Muslim friends and I
spend so much time with these Muslim
friends and it would be very rude of me
to eat or drink in front of them while
they're fasting so I won't do that but
if I'm going to spend that much time
fasting anyway well you know why don't I
just go ahead and fast from dawn to
sunset like they're doing and I sort of
rationalized and half convinced myself I
was just doing this out of common
courtesy for my friends but again I
found a very meaningful yes I began to
do it so now I'm an atypical Christian
who is willing to say the Shahada in
English reading the Quran in English
saying the five prayers in English
fasting during Ramadan but I'm still in
a typical prayer you're kind of driving
the car the Porsche but you're not
calling them that's about where we're at
and again I thought I hadn't all worked
out yeah other people could call me a
Muslim if they wanted to but that wasn't
my you weren't ready label of religious
identity I was at a typical Christian
and I thought I had it all worked out I
I thought I had it planned out perfectly
you know I could believe as my Muslim
friends believed I could practice as my
Muslim friends practice but I could keep
my sense of religious identity of being
a Christian well that lasted for quite a
while but it was late in March of 1993
and my wife and I were now in Jordan
doing that Middle Eastern trip and we
were staying with the extended family of
one of our friends in Denver and one day
uncle omelette motion for me to come
with him uncle Roy I would I would that
was his name I would and he spoke down a
word of English yeah elderly Palestinian
when brother so I got in the car with
him and we drove off and he took me to a
Palestinian refugee camp and we got out
and we started walking down the narrow
lane of the camp and as we were walking
down that Lane another elderly person
came walking towards us who also it
turns out spoke not one word of English
and we met there and we exchanged a
Salam alikoum or peace be upon you and
shook hands and then he turned to me and
he asked me a question in Arabic in
Arabic in Arabic because he spoke no
English yeah now my Arabic was limited
to a few simple words and phrases yes
and that was about it
uh-huh I certainly couldn't hold even an
elementary conversation and everything
but I knew just enough Arabic that I
fully understood this question yes and
this question was are you a Muslim oh
and you know my five-minute verbal jam
gymnastics out the window and out the
window he's utterly useless you know I
knew just enough Arabic that I could
answer mom for yes or LA for now and
those were the only two choices I had
you got set up I was set up set up by
someone far far greater veterans and is
far better planner than hi yeah and I
hummed a little hora praise be to God at
that point in time I said mom or yes but
it took all of that before I was willing
to give up that sense of religious
identity that I had and I think this is
something that people who are involved
in sharing the message of Islam often
fail to appreciate sometimes it's much
easier to get a person to change their
religious beliefs than it is to get them
to change their sense of identity of who
they are that could be very difficult
yeah and you finally with the help of
the creator of the heavens in the earth
and Arabic we say Allah that it finally
happened and now you're writing books on
Islam and helping people understand this
beautiful way of life trying to help
clear the misconceptions could we
briefly they're signalling that
almost out of time tell us now you
mentioned that before you accepted that
okay I'm a Muslim I'm one who's chosen
consciously to submit to the one God
mm-hmm
you said one god what what do you
believe now what do you mean when you
say I believe in the one God but you
don't believe in these other things that
the divinity of Jesus sonship
crucifixion but you said you believe in
one god what does that mean can you
elaborate a little bit about this what
do you actually mean when you read well
I believe in in one God there is one and
only one guy
and that one guy because some Christians
will say we also believe in just one God
well and in point of fact to be fair
yeah they do I mean if you properly
understand the notion of the Trinity
it is monotheistic yeah however from a
Muslim perspective yeah they are adding
partners partners and so they have their
Trinitarian formula three persons and
one substance yeah and for us as Muslims
it's the unity of God there's no three
persons in one substance there is only
God so it's just purely absolutely one
God no co-equal no partner no one along
side with God yeah I know three persons
and one substance no sons or daughters
or any kind of family bloodline DNA no
none of this with God no no okay no
human qualities associated with God God
is far above far above any of these
human deficiencies okay
talk about the five pillars now that you
practice so someone can get a sense of
you know is it something eccentric is
something way far fetched that you know
goes against my nature is it something
that if you can understand this then you
know what this is like the engine this
is what you know makes it run there are
basically five pillars of practice yeah
the first one is saying the testimonial
of a shadow a la ilaha illa-llah heroine
muhammad rasool ullah which much
basically means i testify that there is
no god but God and I testify that
Muhammad peace be upon him was one of
the messengers of that
now does this exclude like Jesus Moses
and all of them absolutely not
absolutely not in fact the Quran tell
we have to accept those profits so is
your relationship now with Jesus do you
feel like stronger do you feel like
you've lost a connection with him no I
don't feel like there's any loss of
connection at all no no of course not
what do you believe about Jesus now
basically what I believed about him
during my years was in a typical
Christian which was he was inspired by
God he received a revelation from God
but he was not God yeah so he was like
the other messengers sure doing what
sharing the the revelation that God gave
to him that's it a teacher teaching us
so King is it safe to say that he was
during his time the way the truth and
the life just like solutely Abraham
Moses and in terms of the message he
preached in fact the word prophet yeah
comes from the Greek and it's a
translation of the Hebrew word never
Ying which in turn comes from the
Akkadian language and if you go back to
that Akkadian language and look at what
what it means it means one who speaks
for ya in a religious context one speaks
for ya it means one who speaks for God
this is what a prophet is yeah one who
speaks for God by definition that makes
sense okay so the belief in one God that
there's no God no deity except the one
guy yes and Muhammad is his last message
and that confirmed all the other
messages that preceded him and then very
quickly the the other four pillars
saying the five prayers of Islam every
day third pillar fasting during Ramadan
fourth pillar paying zakat or obligatory
charity on one's economic surplus and
fifth pillar making the Hajj once a your
adult lifetime now the last three of
those are conditional based upon your
physical and financial well-being what
is it what is this changed your life now
by implementing this is this like a
complete blueprint on how you need to
function from A to Z throughout the day
in many respects yes in some respects
now tell me in terms of know many of the
things I was already basically
practicing yeah you know I you know
before I became a Muslim I did you pork
I did eat pork that was one thing I had
to give would you like the little Jack
Daniels or did you like some you
like I dragged you can't drink now ah I
got dragged maybe once a year
uh-huh one drink a year yeah so I mean I
giving up alcohol that was basically
goes yeah
giving up port that took some getting
used to uh-huh
but those are changes but in terms of
living the sort of ethical life etc
that's not a change and in terms of much
of what I believed it's not a change now
we talked about that main pillar that
one he acknowledges that there's no God
besides the one God and this is
something that just goes with your
nature that you worship God alone you
don't set up a co-equal core partner you
don't pray to Jesus but you pray to the
one Jesus prayed to yes and now the
prayer did you feel like now that since
you're implementing because that's the
second pillar of Islam this prayer was
this having a positive influence and
you're like because who can reject I
mean prayer this is when you ask them is
prayer good just like yeah so you prayed
now five times a day
yeah well the prayer of worship five
times a day yeah you know there's
personal prayer any time any time any
place anything anywhere yeah basically
but yeah in terms of the prayers of
worship the five prayers of worship
every day as I mentioned before even
before I was willing to call myself a
Muslim and I was saying them in English
yeah in private you know I found them
very rewarding yeah you know I found
them spiritually rewarding yeah and I
think a big difference brother it would
be this you know in terms of my belief
structure not that much changed yeah
from going from being an atypical
Christian to being a Muslim so my
intellectual approach to religion didn't
change that yeah
but the spiritual approach that's where
the change what I see you know because I
found this spiritual gratification this
feeling that it's very hard to describe
but is a very very meaningful thing very
comforting thing a very enriching thing
and by following the five pillars you
know I found this spiritual
gratification the sense of spiritual
reward that I was not finding as an
atypical Christian okay just reverse for
a second and then we're going to come
forward and finish things up and then we
want to talk a little bit about your
book but tell us was it as far as can
someone say or did you feel that it was
a kind of back then it was esoteric say
thing we're only now you have to someone
can say you weren't maybe feeling the
Holy Ghost you have to be full of this
to really understand it and you didn't
have it oh I don't know that I want to
use the word Holy Ghost yeah but you
know the spiritual side yeah there
there's where the change was not so much
the intellectual understanding not so
much the the morality and the ethics
uh-huh but in terms of the spiritual the
spiritual gratification and enrichment
the sense maybe this was a better way of
putting it
this sense of being close to God
yeah and is this something that everyone
as I said do you have to get something
that just overtakes you and you're just
on cloud nine or is it something that
you use just your good old common sense
and your intellect and your sincerity
and asking God to guide you that someone
can come to that feeling well I think
different people come to it in different
ways and if you were to interview twenty
different conversation is la Miu
probably would get twenty different
variations and so I think for each
convert they have in some ways their own
unique path whereby they reach God and
reach the truth of God's religion Islam
okay so you have the five pillars tell
us now that you have some books that we
had discussed you have the easy
understanding of Islam
you have the Abrahamic faith you have
Muslim history in America you have
letters to my elders you have a lot of
books here brother we have understanding
Islam the cross and the Crescent where
can someone if they want to they're
intrigued by your story they want to
learn more where can they go to visit
and to pick up some of your books well I
have a website yes
Dierks online books
calm and they can go there and order any
of the books that they want as well as
contact me by email if they choose to
okay that's right there Dierks online
books calm your emails dear somebody
wants to invite you maybe to come speak
do a public lecture you're available for
those yes yes and again they can contact
me with the email that's available on my
website we got to come to and give
please some sincere advice you've been
through a lot in life you have now come
to this realization this is the truth
not everybody has to agree with this
that's right but for that person who is
sincere he is having the same issues
with the identity he doesn't want to
leave possibly the identity of being a
Christian or Buddhist or this or that he
has his inner circle his status and
fears maybe a laws people going to look
at him funny what advice do you have for
this person
well I the advice I would give if you're
wrestling with this issue of religious
identity is don't compound the the
conflict becoming a Muslim does not mean
that you give up your national or your
cultural identity I'm an American I was
born in America I was raised in America
my national cultural identity hasn't
changed at all I'm still an American and
to become a Muslim you don't need to
give up your national identity or your
cultural identity the only identity
under consideration is your religious
identity and so if you've studied the
Bible and the Bible is one of the paths
to Islam I would maintain if you've
studied the Bible if you've done your
research into commentaries if you've
come to the conclusion that there is one
and only one God and that God is unity
not trinity if you've come to the
conclusion that Jesus was inspired by
God and God gave revelation to Jesus but
he was still a human being then please
take a look at Islam because we're
really talking the same language here
and again you don't have to
your national cultural identity to be a
Muslim thank you this is some great
advice and thank you very much for being
with us God willing we're going to have
a special section because we're going to
look forward to
God wanted doing some more topics with
you picking your brain so we can learn
some more from this in-depth knowledge
you have of the Bible and some of your
experiences so more of us including
myself can benefit thank you my pleasure
and I'd like to thank you for being with
us again on a Dean I hope you got the
benefit from dr. dark's story and his
way to Islam and I hope that you
continue to come back visit us here at
the Deen show and we hope that inshallah
God willing that God Almighty guides us
all to the one truth that he guides our
hearts our minds our bodies to accept
that he is the only one to be worshipped
he is the only one that we should turn
to that we should revere that we should
love the one God the God who jesus
prayed to whom Moses prayed to who
Abraham in the last and final messenger
sent to mankind a prophet Muhammad who
he prayed to these were the best
teachers people who we should emulate
because they were showing us how to
praise God to worship God and be close
to God and get to paradise because life
is short this life is very short
transitory it's passing quickly and they
all taught that there's a better life
there's a paradise waiting and that's
what we're trying to get to and we knees
got it and we need God's help to get to
that paradise again what everyone's
talking about
but the argument here is that God out of
his love because in all honesty if you
really wanted to do something you're
gonna find the way where there's the
world there's a way absolutely yes there
are a few problems here why were people
of generations and generations and
generations being told to worship one
God asked that God for forgiveness ask
him for for salvation seek His mercy no
one else's which is the last
I was 16 years eight years in active
reservist and eight years active dude
but the bottom line is that I'm an
ophthalmologist I'm specialist in
cataract and effective surgery and
medical director of the major eyes we
have a question from a Christian who
says I was born a Christian I was raised
a Christian wants to take a look it
challenges the reader who if you find
one contradiction it can't be from God
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to obey
your Lord you will fall short nobody's
perfect all of us make mistakes you do
your best and then expect from God's
mercies what's the purpose of my life
why am I here is it just a play have fun
go to the nightclubs kick it on the
weekends earn some money have a good
time and then I die she's really not
looking to get into a relationship just
to kind of you know wham bam thank you
ma'am
and walk away from it it's the way that
men are why do I have to convert to
Islam if God made me a Christian if God
made my family a Christian then why
should I change that way because God is
the one who created me in that way most
atheists when they pray they pray this
way they say Oh God if you are there by
random messengers who start with Adam
Abraham Moses David Suleiman and Jesus
and we say peace and blessings be upon
all of them I made a promise to my
trader on that day I promised that if he
would save the life of my child and
alone running this universe that he
doesn't become born he doesn't die he
doesn't eat and go to the bathroom he's
not a man that has an area code a zip
code now you consider
fingerprint him
take his picture and the girl he's cute
a lot of you out there know exactly what
I'm talking about
a lot of you out there are in the exact
same position he said I would never give
up for spring guy that's why I wouldn't
never give up spreading this message
okay you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow so you got to find that urgency
to do the right thing right now
just when firefighter everything for us
that's what I do
majority people you talk to yeah they
know they got to change they know they
got to do good but they don't do the
good why is this the ranking of the 100
most influential men in the history of
the world laziness
the reality of life usually that you
sink in until tragedy comes you know
this is when you find people yeah yeah
okay tell me about it yeah you got a few
bad people the media grabs a hold of
that and spends it the way they want to
and in it he puts Muhammad is number one
he said no human being had more
influence one of the amazing things
about Islam that everyone should know is
that we are the only other religion that
is a tenet of faith that you must
believe in Jesus Christ and everything
that he did or you cannot be understand
if that is missing if you say that you
do not believe in Jesus you have stepped
outside of his name you cannot be a
Muslim is attended our faith to to
believe in and love Jesus Christ
these are not God God is the one who
created everything in his universe
that's the one I'm gonna worship and
prostrate to how can you go wrong doing
that don't believe it I'm you're out of
this long and I'm gonna top 10 reasons
why Jesus cannot be God let's get right
to it not be God number 10 glad you did
you